morning welcome to sky news breakfast
thank you for joining us
thousands of english football fans have
descended on the portuguese city of
porto ahead of the uefa
champions league final later today in
the biggest mass departure from the uk
since the pandemic it's only the third
ever all english final in
european football's biggest competition
with manchester city and chelsea
contesting the prize
portugal stepped in three weeks ago to
host the event with the country on the
uk's green list
fans avoid quarantine in both directions
but with cases of the indian variant
rising here in the uk
some in portugal believe inviting so
many fans over to the game
is an unnecessary risk as our sports
correspondent martha kellner reports
and they're back the unmistakable sight
and sound
of english fans abroad
[Applause]
portuguese police intervened on a couple
of occasions last night
to diffuse what was largely good-natured
rivalry
between manchester city and chelsea
supporters
throughout the day they commandeered one
of the prettiest corners of this city
twelve thousand ticket holders and many
more are in porto
this is the biggest mass departure from
the uk since before the pandemic
and under a watchful presence wetting
their appetite for the biggest club
match in world
like a little bit of football in europe
again yes definitely
normality is definitely coming back and
i would say to everyone [ __ ] holiday and
get over here for this son
how much have you paid to get out here
in total we're taking everything
out of brandon this final was originally
slated for istanbul but was moved to
portugal because the country's on the uk
government's travel
green list the beautiful setting of
porto
is just a bonus but with the indian
covered variant on the rise in england
and so many fans traveling here
there's no doubt that this city has
taken a risk
but the mayor says it's worth it the
fact is people need to work
and this gives the city a new a new life
i see so many people in the street this
morning i was walking in the street
plenty of people around and the cafes
are full
people are enjoying and and we are
showing the city which is so important
and then of course
remember porto is a city where people
like the game they love the game
for manchester city it's the first
european final in 51 years
for this man a chance to crown a
reputation already cemented as the most
influential manager of a generation i'm
pretty sure we have to suffer to win the
finals it's not
uh you know go out there and enjoy so
it's worth it's night but sometimes it's
not possible so
sometimes you have most of the times in
the finals you have to suffer
you have to be resilient chelsea are the
slight underdogs despite having beaten
city twice this season
their manager thomas tuchel giving his
squad some light relief with an
impression of his opposite number
guardiola until he spotted the camera
watching
i will never suggest that it's me
against him because we don't we don't
have a match of tennis we arrive with
our teams and
pep will prepare his team and i will
prepare my team in the best way possible
i we have two experiences now against
them in different competitions
and two different matches to different
lineups
last year the champions league trophy
was lifted before
empty stands today many of these
supporters will be inside
the stadio do dragao but the joy of
having them back is tempered by a fear
among police
that the negative aspects of england's
travelling fans
may return to martha kellner sky news
porto one of the experts who helped
change number 10 coveted policy in the
first wave of curvid
has warned about the risk of easing
restrictions too quickly
speaking to the guardian newspaper
professor sir tim gowers whose argument
against a herd immunity strategy helped
trigger england's first lockdown
says things will get bad very quickly
after june
if the variant spread is underestimated
well it comes as the latest figures show
that the number of new daily coronavirus
cases in the uk has passed
four thousand for the first time since
the first of april
four thousand one hundred and eighty two
new coronavirus cases have been
confirmed
ten more deaths have been reported which
means the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
now stands at 127 768.
another 256
people have received their first
vaccination
and 434 096 people
have received their second 24.48 million
people in the uk
have now received both doses of a
coronavirus
vaccine now correspondent emma birchley
joins me now from
the newsroom uh and emma what's the very
latest we're hearing about the impact
that this rise
in coronavirus cases might have on the
easing of restrictions on june the 21st
well what we've got today is a pretty
dire warning about what would happen
if the move out of lockdown happens too
fast we keep hearing about this indian
variant and that is what's causing
so much concern and the prime minister
has made it clear all along that every
step out of lockdown as part of his
robot
map should be irreversible he doesn't
want to be doing u-turns
and that's why this professor sir tim
gowers says extreme caution should be
taken
when going into each step of the road
map the next one of course being june
the 21st now he goes on to say
maybe everything will be okay maybe the
number of people who are vaccinated will
be just enough
uh will broadly speaking stay below one
even with indian variants
but if it's not okay we know because of
mathematics that things will get bad
very very quickly or at least maybe it
won't look that quick to start with
but it'll grow exponentially so what
he's saying is it will really
pick up speed and we know that the r
number
has already crept above one we know that
week on week the number of people
testing positive chronovirus
has increased by 24 but of course we
have got this very successful
vaccination program
nearly three-quarters of people have
received one dose
nearly half of all adults have received
two doses and actually when you look at
the cases
of the indian variant only three percent
of people
have actually received both doses so
it's clearly
working but i think the key word at the
moment is
caution and the government obviously
taking that on board because they have
delayed a review
into that date of june the 21st of
whether that will be the next step
out of lockdown
music festivals are facing the prospect
of another lost
summer as a result of the government's
decision not to introduce a coronavirus
insurance scheme
that's the conclusion of a cross-party
report into the future of the uk's
summer circuit which is calling on
ministers to provide a safety net for
live events scheduled to take place
after the 21st of june our political
correspondent joe
pike reports
in east london finishing touches are
being made to a mini festival
that is going ahead where many others
aren't
but for the organizers it's still a big
financial risk
there's so much expenditure when you're
booking an event like that like the main
thing will be artist costs
but then also you have things like you
know the actual insurance for
like hunters and all of the costs of
like actually physically
getting crew and staging and all that
kind of stuff on the grounds like it's
an incredibly
like it's a hugely expensive endeavor
and with one summer loss to covid
the prospect of having to scrap a second
is scary
one year maybe you can like survive it
but two years then
probably not to go where you've never
gone before
today a cross-party group of mps is
criticizing the government
for refusing to back all important
insurance for the industry
they face frankly losing their homes and
their businesses
if they have to cancel due to cobit
so what we would like to see is the
government to do exactly the same things
is done with film and tv
and to introduce an insurance scheme
which means
that sugar festival have to cancel due
to kobit they won't end up
losing absolutely everything
pre-pandemic the uk had 1 000 music
festivals a year
with over 5 million attendees
contributing nearly 2 billion pounds to
the economy
a key ask really there is for government
to back its own road map
um i think you know a lot of people
think that this
insurance intervention is about money
and about injecting that but
it's actually not because it wouldn't
cost the government the taxpayer a
single penny
if the road map proceeds accordingly
in a statement the government argues we
are continuing to work
flat out to support festivals and live
events
our events research program has explored
how festivals can get back
up and running safely and festival
organizers have received more than 34
million pounds
from our unprecedented culture recovery
fund with more support on the way
back in east london this weekend some
will be getting their first taste of
live music
for over a year but for other festivals
even if the government does change its
policy on insurance
it may all be too late joe pike sky news
well let's get some more now on the
state of coronavirus in the uk
i'm joined by debbie street our
professor in global public health at the
university of edinburgh good morning to
you
um how worried should we be that the
number of coronavirus cases has passed
four thousand for the first time since
the first of april
well we can definitely see you creep up
and that um right now we're waiting to
see
can we break that link between cases
going up and hospitalizations and deaths
rising as we saw in the previous waves
so i say the good news for people is
that two doses of vaccine
look incredibly protective but if you've
only had one dose or you're waiting to
get your vaccine
you are exposed and so just be more
cautious it's a matter of weeks now and
you know the british people are lucky we
get our vaccines within weeks a large
part of the world won't get vaccines for
years
so tim gows the cambridge professor who
helped trigger the first
lockdown says the indian variant could
pick up speed
and become a big problem i quote things
could get bad
very very quickly yeah i mean i think we
should take his words very seriously
he's incredibly intelligent and
experienced and i think
what he's saying is that there are two
things we're worried about with the
indian variant the first is it more
transmissible does it jump faster
between people
and as i said there's still a lot of
people who've only had one dose and are
waiting on their second
or younger people in their 20s and 30s
who are not even having their first dose
yet
and they can just jump between those
people incredibly quickly and take off
and the second thing is how much vaccine
evasion could there be potentially
right now it seems that vaccines are
holding up relatively well
but there could be mutations in the
future which make it more problematic so
i guess it's a warning to all of us that
whenever we think this is behind us
there are new challenges ahead so we
have to proceed cautiously because we're
on a good path now
let's just hold our ground instead of
trying to move too quickly and then
ending up in you know
back 10 steps so so is he right when he
says that the downside of being
a bit more cautious as a lot smaller
than the disadvantages of
of getting things wrong at this stage
agreed completely because we know that
right now we have opened up substantial
parts of the economy we have kids in
school
we have more and more normality in our
lives and so it's better to hold where
we are now
and progress very very carefully so we
hold those gains
rather than you know moving too quickly
and then getting back into a
stay-at-home lockdown like we've been
through several times we don't want to
go back there
nobody wants to lock down so it's about
saying right now
let's hold where we are let's see how we
get forward let's get those vaccines out
but not to be let's say over promising
to people that everything's going to be
the end of the pandemic is happening
within weeks i mean i think people now
realize that every time that's been said
we've learned that it's not actually
true and so i think just having that
caution but also that optimism
that things will get better because the
tools that we have are much much better
than they were a year back
and the projections do look relatively
positive as you're suggesting because we
do have
the johnson johnson vaccine which has
come online now and also
the um progressing of the second
vaccination bringing that uh further
forward for people
yeah exactly i think that's great news
fantastic we have this new jab that's
just once you need to get
you don't even go back for your two
doses um you know once we start getting
that ruled out
i mean the real thing we're looking for
is can we stop hospitalizations
can we stop serious illness and deaths
if we can find a way to do this then
there is a way to manage this that was
always the aim of science to make this
manageable
like other diseases we had and for the
past year it has not been manageable
because we haven't had a way to stop
people getting
really ill and dying and even people
being prolonged illness through long
covid
now we have vaccines which offer one
tool among several
including testing including um you know
now includes better therapeutics to mean
we can manage this
and i think the second thing to say is
i'm very worried about our border
policies
we've just seen an investigation by sky
showing that
a million and a half people came through
in the past you know four months of 2021
and when we were in lockdown and that
two-thirds of them were not uk nationals
i think that's a huge risk we have in
terms of importing a variant that will
prove problematic
so i don't understand while while we
cannot travel to india if you are not a
national that you are not letting
nationals in
you can travel from there here even if
you're not a national here
so i think there are real questions
about our border policies that sky has
raised which i just find
have less left vulnerable to this
variant now spreading and creating a
difficult situation in terms of how fast
we have to move
okay professor debbie schwedhel thank
you very much for sharing your expertise
with us thank you
let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the news this
morning and president biden says the
united states
is drawing up a list of targeted
sanctions against key members of the
belarusian government
following the forced landing of orion
airplane and the detention of a
journalist
these include preventing americans from
doing business with nine belarusian
companies
the white house press secretary also
said last night that the administration
would prevent belarus from using u.s
airspace
detectives investigating the shooting of
the anti-racism campaigner sasha johnson
have charged a man with conspiracy to
murder
sasha was shot in southeast london in
the early hours of last sunday
and remains in a critical condition in
hospital
head teachers have been warned by the
education secretary to ensure there's
political impartiality
in discussions on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in schools
following an increase in anti-semitism
gavin williamson said the recent
violence in gaza
has led to anti-jewish bullying of both
students and
teachers writing to schools mr
williamson said teachers
should avoid bias in political
discussions and that schools should not
work with groups that reject israel's
right to exist
thousands of asylum seekers in the uk
are struggling to access financial
support
after the government changed the way it
distributes money to them
a prepaid bank card meant to be loaded
with 39 pounds a week
has been replaced by a new card but some
say these either haven't arrived
don't work or don't have any money on
them sadia chowdhury reports
walter's lifeline came to a halt last
friday
escaping gang violence in central
america he's seeking asylum here in the
uk
and the home office gives him about 40
pounds a week on a prepaid card
to help pay for things like food
clothing and toiletries
but a recent change in the way the home
office issues these cards
has left walter and thousands of others
like him
without food for days we just try to
keep it for the baby
because with my wife like adults we
we know that we can support a little bit
more but
if the baby is different but now that we
don't have not food
it's really critical it's really
critical because we don't know
what else we can do it's the same story
for this woman who chose not to be named
she lives in a housing complex for
asylum seekers
where she says around 30 families have
yet to receive cards
it's a desperate situation i literally
thought of selling some of our clothes
since i'm not allowed to work i i
thought about selling some of our
clothes to to get some
some help until the the cart or the card
arrives
charities say a string of problems with
the new cards has left families hungry
now for over a week
the significance of the problem is that
they only get 39 pounds 63 to live on a
week and that is such a tiny amount
and when you when you're on such a low
amount you know you're not making any
savings you don't have any backup it's
real hand-to-mouth
so even being without it for a couple of
days was a big problem being without it
with a week
it's a disaster i mean they don't people
don't have food we are
signposting people to food banks we're
getting phone calls from people who
literally haven't eaten
you know it's really significant the
home office told us
those who have issues or are unsure how
they can activate their cards are able
to contact the 24 7 migrant help
helpline
accommodation providers can facilitate
emergency cash payments in the meantime
walter says the helpline gave him no
assistance and he's been turned away by
charities inundated with requests as an
asylum seeker he's not allowed to work
while his claim is being considered
until his new card arrives walter has no
way to feed his family
sadia chowdhury sky news
now says uh here with all of the good
news we are smiling
i'm having a barbie on sunday and it's
going to be lovely isn't it
oh yeah well yeah you're all invited no
you're not
will there be baileys or other drinks
similar to that i'm sure there will be
yeah okay
great um well it's looking good if you
are doing any outdoor activity for this
a bang holiday weekend most places will
be dry
and bright and warm finally some
spring-like weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning looking mostly fine for
this bank holiday weekend finally some
spring-like conditions and in fact for
the last day of the meteorological
spring which is bank holiday monday
we could actually record the highest
temperature of the whole of spring at
2021.
we need to beat 24.5 degrees celsius
that was
the highest back on the 30th of march so
it has been a rather cool and wet uh
spring
this year quite cloudy and cool this
morning as well in fact
and murky around some eastern areas some
missed fog car and fret around some
eastern coastal counties most of that
will lift and clear until this afternoon
we should see some bright or sunny
spells developing but it may take some
time for it to brighten up across
parts of wales but there should be some
sunny spells developing there
a weak front though across western areas
of the uk may produce one or two showers
where currently
it is bringing some patchy light rain
and drizzle around some central and
western areas
in the sunshine though the strong may
sunshine it will feel
warm for today for most places there
will be sunshine by the end of the day
as well
and it will be mainly dry but eastern
coastal counties rather murky and cool
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
jackie's here walking on sunshine aren't
you we're all happy because i dream
about walking on sunshine actually we've
had a bit of sun this week have we a lot
of rain a bit of sun
hopefully it'll be sunny for one of
these two teams tonight will it be
chelsea
will it be manchester city we've got
more build up to the all
english champions league final as the
city goalkeeper edison shows why he
could be taking a penalty
if it goes to a shootout plus it's also
the championship player final at wembley
this afternoon we'll hear from the
brentford and swansea managers
as they look to secure a place in the
premier league
an incredible story in darts as welshman
johnny clayton wins the premier league
title
at his first attempt but his 250 000
pound winners prize
isn't enough to stop him from quitting
his full-time job
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables from houses
schools and businesses in order to
recycle them
in exchange of your recyclable to get a
tree
[Music]
jackie's here can hardly contain herself
all english
final i'm so excited it's not my team
i'm not that excited
i'm actually i think it's an amazing
achievement and um interesting to see
who will be walking out of the estadio
de dragao with the champions league
trophy and who will be walking out of
wembley
and into the premier league today let's
have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
the world has been waiting longer for an
olympic games than any time since world
war
ii but for the athletes still hoping to
qualify
time is fast running out skateboarding
is the new kid on the block
full of new kids ready to slide into the
mainstream
i feel like it might always kind of be
thought of
like the sort of like delinquent sport
but
you know we're breaking away from that a
little bit don't let the american accent
fool you
this 14 year old is more full english
than eggs over easy
i like to make the joke that i'm
a half a new yorker three-fourths of
rummy
i mean i spent so much of my childhood
in birmingham because my dad's british
so many people they bust on british food
but it's so
good like a full like english fry up at
for dinner look it's so good
skateboarding made its
x games debut in 1995 and 26 years later
it will bring a blend of
high risk action and technical artistry
to shake up the establishment
to drop in once takes guts but bombat
comes from a fighting family my
grandfather has a boxing gym
in erdington called the rosen crown and
so i spent a lot of time there when i
was little
and my dad used to train there he
actually
was trying to go to the olympics himself
he was close for no cigar
it'll take every bit of that competitive
edge to make
team gb skateboarders from around the
world are battling it out at qualifying
events like this one between now and
june
to try and accumulate enough points to
make the games
bombett needs to land in the top 20 in
the world
to keep her dream of reaching the top
alike my
words that was fantastic
ben ransom sky sports
the global pandemic has impacted hard on
all aspects of the winter sports
industry
five-time olympic skier graham bell
portrays a landscape ravaged by closed
resorts and little positive news
pretty much all of the alpine uh
countries
have have closed their lifts uh apart
from switzerland
uh which has kind of stayed kind of in
the game
but from a british perspective uh with
with the lockdown and with the travel
ban
you know i really can't see there being
any
british ski season but it's not all doom
and gloom
there is light at the end of the tunnel
a recent independent delphi study
involving
53 experts predicts the pandemic may
have actually boosted the industry's
chances of a sustainable revival
this may sound a little far-fetched for
a sport that is by definition a close to
nature
experience due to our experts they
believe that
covet 19 will accelerate the
technological innovation and
digitization in the winter sports
industry
and so i think this let us
look into the future with a little smile
on our faces
the experts predict participation across
all sectors of the industry
including those with disabilities will
increase as advancements in e-sports
drive the industry forward
by 2025 you may be able to race against
your heroes on a virtual slope
and the idea of a virtual ski world
championship is not just a pipe dream
the technology side of things has really
improved as well you know
you have you mentioned uh you know
esports uh i think winter sports has
been quite slow to adopt that but if you
look at the success of
formula one with the way that they did
their you know esports i think that that
will
help winter sports if they introduce
that as well
and you can capture some of the you know
some of the people who want to go
skiing but perhaps can't it seems that
by overcoming these hurdles the ski
industry may turn a long-term downfall
into long-term gains jp barrel sky
sports
[Music]
my name is alan keane i am 26 years old
i am from dublin ireland i am a
paralympic swimmer
i am a european champion from 2018 and i
also won a paralympic bronze battle at
the rio
2016 paralympic games
i am hyper happy and think i'm gas
my biggest highlight has been winning
gold at the european championships here
in dublin in 2018
and then my low point i think maybe even
locked in it's just it has been so hard
long uncertain committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
this is scani's breakfast coming up
we'll be speaking to the presenter vicky
patterson who's
nearly completed her overnight challenge
aiming to raise money
for homelessness charities
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching sky news
breakfast now the pandemic has
highlighted concerns about
youth homelessness with the charity
center point saying the uk was at crisis
point
even before covert over the last year
calls to the charities helpline from
young people worried about homelessness
have increased by about a third to
highlight the issue a number of stars
including our next guest have gone a
whole night without sleep
hoping to raise money for homeless young
people so we're joined now by the
presenter
and queen of the jungle vicki patterson
who's uh in the last half hour of her
sleepless night um good morning to you
vicky i bet the morning hasn't come
around soon enough for you and have you
managed through the night
oh hi pal you look so fresh i'm so
jealous uh
i'm on i'm really it's the last stretch
isn't it
and i'm sorry if i'm a little bit
tongue-tied
um i am feeling super tired now looking
a little bit like a
little mole as well um not me finest and
glamorous
hour but it's all for a very good cause
isn't it
yes it is indeed uh tell us how you
managed to stay awake
through the night i mean you were doing
various uh activities weren't you
yeah you know what i i couldn't have
done it like we had a last-minute
substitution
uh my mom came off the bench she wasn't
even signed up to do the event i was
meant to be doing it with my boyfriend
but um my mom has stayed up with us um
and
she's been doing a jigsaw for most of
the night she's having a great time
she's been an excellent moral support
we've watched some films did a little
workout with mr mota vida
i've had my lovely little doggy keeping
me company
we've done some self-care up all night
as well oh
this one absolutely not total fraud he's
been catching cat naps the whole time
but
he's so fluffy and cute i let him off
yes i do
i love it the dog catching cat naps and
so tell us why you've done this why you
put yourself through this
um a couple years ago actually it was
mainly mom um became aware of the work
that center point do
we did at a sleepout event for them um
which was their event
um before the pandemic obviously where
people got together and experienced a
glimmer
of what it must be like um to be young
and homeless
um but given the current climate we you
can't do that we can't have loads of
people sleeping on the streets for this
so
and this event in particular was was the
new one
um and after speaking to the center
point i realized
the year that we've had has been
horrible for everybody we've all had our
hardships and our struggles
but nobody has suffered more than young
people um if you look at the industries
that have been affected
most by the corporate 19 virus and the
pandemic it's
retail it's hospitality and who works in
those young people
so more so than ever now you've got
young people who can't pay their rent
who are facing homelessness
and i just felt like this pandemic had
exacerbated an already really tenuous
situation
and i knew that center point needed any
help and any sort of um
yeah the figures are quite shocking
aren't they uh center point saying 120
000 young people
uh face homelessness between 2019 and
2020
uh and that's increased by more than 10
000. so as you say
the situation exacerbated by the
pandemic
absolutely um i know i know we've all
had hard years and things like that
but there's now more than ever center a
point need for help
um they have a huge goal to end youth
homelessness
um and i think if anybody can can do a
bit whether it's
donating sponsoring and signing up to
sponsor like a room
you can do that i just think if it's
within your realm of capabilities we
should give it a go
bit of kindness goes a long way on earth
no absolutely
and three years ago as you were saying
that you slept outside with a hundred
volunteers in in sunderland i think
on that occasion uh the charity raised
what 300 000
pounds how much are you hoping to raise
this time round
oh god i'd love to smash that like i
think
it's a big ask because i know
everybody's had
a very difficult year but i think
what this year has shown were is that we
need to show everybody a bit more
kindness
we need to be supporting each other um
and just yeah being nice to our fellow
man so i think we've got this in the bag
i think we're going to smash it
do we know specifically what the money
will be spent on
so center point helped with a number of
things including
housing education vocational skills
health care mental health physical
health and it goes across the board i've
met a number of
brilliant people who first hand have
been helped by centerpoint
to turn their lives around to realize
that being homeless
being homeless experiencing homelessness
it doesn't have to be
who you are doesn't have to define you
it isn't your story it can just be a
chapter
and there is something bright and
amazing for you after that so
um i know that whatever they do with
their money it's going to be changing
the lives of young people and it's going
to be incredible
yeah very positive indeed vicky thank
you so much for
speaking to us you've got about 20
minutes left hold in there
you can do it thank you it's good to
know you believe in us
thanks for speaking to us stay awake bye
time now to take a look at the weather
for you goodness
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's looking mostly bright
fine and warm for this bank holiday we
weekend believe it or not
right at the end of the meteorological
spring we're finally getting
temperatures around average or a little
above for the time of year
and with mostly settle conditions it's a
cool and cloudy affair out there for
this morning though and there are some
patchy outbreaks of light
rain and drizzle particularly across
parts of wales and parts of the midlands
and central england
and further east it's a bright start but
there are some rather murky conditions
around coastal parts
but it soon brightens up into this
afternoon with a strong may sunshine
we'll
see plenty of it later but as you can
see we'll take some time for it to
brighten up across parts of wales
eventually it will there though and
there will be some sunny spells but
well we've got that weak feature across
western parts of the uk bringing that
patchy light rain at the moment
it will uh tend to break up into some
showers that could be quite
heavy but they're very well scattered
showers across parts of the north and
west of the uk generally speaking it's
dry for today and warm and bright but
eastern coastal cloud is quite murky and
cool
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's at 7 41 coming up next to look at
the newspapers with the anthropologist
marianna hotter and the editor of
challenges northern ireland thomas
copeland do stay with us
i think i knew from the age of about two
that i seem to be different but
um because no one picked up on it i just
assumed i was broken in some way
um and i spent four decades believing
that nobody could fix me but i was just
there's something wrong with me
for instance meltdowns which i've been
you know i've had since i was tiny
um they're really really scary and um if
you don't know that you're having a
meltdown
and you're like 35 it's terrifying
whereas now i
because i'm aware that i'm autistic it
means that i can give myself a bit more
of a break i can go okay
my senses are overwhelmed i need to go
somewhere dark i need to be alone
like i can manage it a little better so
um you know it's it's
it's more about learning more about
yourself and and how to
um be kind to yourself essentially
because you know i spent decades
beating myself up for everything i
couldn't do instead of celebrating the
things that i could
and the reason i wanted to write the
book was that i spent my childhood
looking for people like me in books and
not really finding them
um so when i wrote the character you
know i knew nothing about autism at all
and i was writing about this girl who is
is
is socially um inept would be a nice
word
um you know who climbs under tables when
she's overwhelmed she can't really
process emotions
and you know all the things that i had
gone through that i just felt like i
hadn't seen in literature
um and it wasn't until i know they came
out eight years ago and it wasn't until
my diagnosis that i suddenly looked to
harriet and went
oh my goodness she is obviously also
autistic
we just didn't know that that was what
it was we just thought we were freaks
essentially
it's terrifying going out and speaking
it's not something that's in my skill
set really i'm
i'm very very scared but it it i do
think that you know from the messages
i've had
even even now like that it is helping
young girls
and women in men as well um to to see
themselves and understand themselves
better and it's removing some of that
stigma
because essentially the spectrum is not
a linear spectrum it's not mild to
severe it is a
color wheel and or to see people fall on
it in a different place
and you don't necessarily know what that
looks like or how that presents
and so i think it's really important to
show that you know essentially
um you you don't necessarily know what
people are going through
internally or behind closed doors and
hopefully that will help
younger people see themselves especially
younger people that's my focus
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news entertainment podcast
for wherever you are welcome to
safety ridge what's the day podcast for
the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
from sky news sky news podcasts
listen and subscribe for free did you
know
pollen levels tend to be higher in the
morning and at night
the pollen reports sponsored by phillips
connected air purifiers
after a largely cloudy morning most
places will brighten up this afternoon
with sunny spells
the best of any sunshine will be across
eastern parts of the uk although north
sea coastal counties
may stay rather murky and cool it'll be
mainly dry and warm too for most places
but a few well scattered showers can't
be ruled out
pollen levels today will be moderate for
most of england
and low elsewhere across wales northern
ireland and scotland
the grass pollen season is in its early
stage but some symptoms
may occur on sunny days for some people
however oak tree pollen and fungal
spores
are at a medium risk the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers the anthropologist mariana
hotter and the editor of
challengers northern ireland thomas
copeland welcome back to you
both starting with you first of all
marianne and this is in the
telegraph really looking at the
repercussions of children being out of
school for so long but one of the
solutions
a longer school day perhaps not the best
way
to help them catch up it's being
suggested
uh yeah this is uh results from
a report conducted by
researchers at the department of
education research at cambridge
university
and basically they're saying that longer
school hours so extending the school day
say from 8am to 5pm
in order to try and help kids catch up
particularly children
from more deprived backgrounds
might not actually do that much it'll do
a little bit
it'll help a little bit with english a
little bit with maths but they're saying
basically more of the
the researchers are saying more of the
same
isn't going to be as useful um
as improving quantity improving quality
rather than quantity so actually
investing additional funds in a better
range of activities
better quality of teaching and i i say
that but with the proviso that
our teachers are an amazing force for
good in our children's lives and this is
not bashing the quality of teaching
but so many schools are cash strapped
and they're having to make very
difficult choices about
what kind of resources they fund or what
staff they employ because they can't do
everything they want to do they can't do
all the things that they know
would benefit the children in their care
it's time though it's time though that
they've missed out on
surely the solution is to replace it
with more time
well it's it's kind of what you do with
that time as well so if we
are going to increase the the school
working day
then what we need to also do is not just
more
hot housing for english and maths
because that will help a little bit but
not as much
as increasing time for things like
arts crafts music play outside
sports and crucially time for children
to socialize
as well as the skills for learning to
learn
so not just kind of doing kind of rote
learning of maths and english but
actually
developing those skills that make you
able to learn
for a lifetime because that that's
what's going to improve your mental
health your emotional well-being your
resilience and ultimately
the bottom line your value to the
economy yeah
and i think uh actually relearning how
to to socialize is
is key because they've been so
unaccustomed to being around
other children during this period um
another area that's um
had a severe um real
sort of um difference is in terms of
the backlog in terms of surgery but
you've had a look at thomas this is in
the express there's a huge backlog
and the express saying that we need
these particular to help
hubs to cope with it that's right this
has been one of the major downsides to
the lockdown i suppose
you know alongside children's education
has been the effect that this has had on
the backlog
in our nhs so this article in particular
talks about hip and knee operations
the main one that sort of strikes me
jumps out at me is cancer diagnosis
and especially early cancer diagnosis i
mean it can be weeks and months can
really make the difference in terms of
cancer
and getting diagnosed early is so
important and over the course of this
pandemic thousands i
i would dare to say tens of thousands of
cancer operations or appointments
i should say early doors diagnosis have
been cancelled
and that will have a detrimental impact
over the next number of years because
every week and month that goes by
severely diminishes uh chances of
survival so this is serious stuff
now this reports uh brought by the royal
college of surgeons
suggests that 4.9 people as of march
uh this is probably only england
specific but it doesn't say specifically
where it applies to probably england 4.9
people waiting on starting operations
so a huge number of people have been
delayed as a consequence of this
pandemic
so stark is the problem in northern
ireland for example the health minister
robin swan this week released a
statement saying that unless there was
radical action
the finding principle of the nhs that it
would be free at the point of use
would be fundamentally undermined such
would be the lengths of the waiting
lists
and elsewhere i know in the mirror today
they're talking about waiting lists of
four years
plus for some types of operations of
course then the other problem here is
that you know inequality sets in
people who can pay to go private can do
so
and that means that the people who are
left behind have to wait even
longer um now this article is suggesting
a one billion pound over five years to
set up
surgical hubs to deal with some of these
issues the problem that jumps out with
me and it's one that we've seen
you know persistently in the health
sector is that long-term funding is
needed five years
you know is a is a long time but in that
time uh
you won't be able to re completely train
that many doctors completely train that
many nurses build entirely new hospitals
healthcare is one of those issues that
requires very long-term funding
and in our system political system
that's difficult to do because you have
five-year terms so in order to get sort
of 10 and 20-year plans
that's enormously difficult to achieve
this
issue of long waiting lists will be the
next medical emergency in this country
and it needs to be treated with the same
kind of urgency as covert
moving away from the repercussions of
the pandemic
let's have a look at the star front page
not something we
often do at marianne but uh tell us why
a four day working week
could save the planet i know look at
that the star
isn't it good so basically this idea
is um based on a report that has uh
recently
just been published saying that
basically if we
all move to a full day working week with
no
loss of pay so you're not having your
pay cut by 20
you're just doing your job in four days
getting the same salary
we would reduce our emissions in the uk
by 127 million
tons so that's our carbon footprint and
that doesn't
mean that much to me that figure no no
probably you either
and that's a 20 21 reduction
overall which is equivalent to removing
every single private car
off all our roads so it's pretty
significant
now how does that work well it's by
reducing energy usage
reducing commuting so some of these
figures will have to be adjusted if
people continue to work from home
because of
covid and and kind of those changes to
flexible working patterns
but bottom line is it'll still be a
massive reduction
and with that extra day that you get
where you're not at work
the argument is that we can actually
live more sustainable lifestyles now
this isn't kind of radical
you know psychedelic thinking this is
stuff that most of us want to do things
like spending more time with your family
spending more time with your friends
spending a bit more time doing exercise
or leisure pursuits
and those generally are activities that
have a low
carbon cost a sort of a low input
local input but you're not having to
commute you're not getting fast food
well i was gonna say that that's if
you're not driving all over the place to
to do those activities where isn't it
um yeah to some extent generally
uh overall when you kind of look at a
look at the statistics from a
population-wide perspective
the reduction will still be significant
so let's do it
yeah i mean who's going to say no to a
four-day week on the same pay
they're not going to get much resistance
to that
to the telegraph thomas english
reluctance
to pay for scotland to stay
yeah this is an interesting one at a
pool in the telegraph revealing what
will be
the problem at the heart of the union
which is that english voters aren't
really fuss
about the union so as sturgeon secures
another
uh government another term in scotland
this poll reveals that only 20 of
english people
strongly oppose independence then 32
percent oppose it
and a surprisingly large 25 percent of
english
respondents in this survey said that
they actually supported scottish
independence
unsurprisingly then the next step a
minority
a severe minority of english voters are
in favor of increasing money being sent
to scotland in order to sort of
shore up the union and you know i can
understand why scotland already enjoys
17
higher in term public spending per heads
than for example
the uk average east midlands let's make
a comparison east midlands
10 below the uk average so if you are
for example maybe
you know a working-class person in the
east midlands you're looking at scotland
where the the uk wide barnet formula
largely paid for by english taxpayers is
funding at the scottish social care
system
and then you've also got nicholas
sturgeon saying scots are being trapped
in the union we need to get out
you can understand why you mightn't be
too fussed on maintaining the union
um now all of these things need to be
set in context and the overall amounts
of money are small and there are
different levels of deprivation across
the uk
but i think you know the take out from
this for boris johnson
and he will need to be the person that
is keeping an eye on this because unless
there is some severe and drastic work
done he's going to be sort of the latter
day lord north
and he will not want his reputation to
be the end of the union
and mary anne we have run out of time
but we shall see you in the next hour
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
[Music]
experience
so
so
you